oh  [Music]  our team is the elite of the elite  the heart and soul of this very beach  we protect when no one wants to protect  and we go above and  this has beyond to do with saving people  these are refrigerators oh this is  baywatch [ __ ]  [Applause]  [Music]  there's more to this job than just  swimming  victoria leeds the new owner of the  hampton club drugs murder  all this started once leeds took over i  thought we were lifeguards everything  that you guys were talking about sounds  like a really entertaining but  far-fetched tv  show does she always look like she's  running in slow-mo wow you see it too  aren't you trying to be a hero  some bait watch [ __ ]  grab my hand  you turn the canals into the goddamn  x-games yeah that's cause we were in  lifeguard pursuit there's no [ __ ]  such thing as lifeguard pursuit even if  you were police what you did would still  be totally illegal okay well i mean it's  good thing we're not police then  you